[Music]
let go out to Phoenix Arizona and talk
to my my my Miranda what's up
Miranda hi what
up uh I'm just excited to speak with you
today thank you for taking the time to
talk to me of course I'm grateful that
you called what's
up well I have a question um and so I'll
just I'll tell you my question up
front um I'm going through the process
of a divorce I'm waiting for it to be
finalized and I'm wondering when it's
helpful to speak up about abuse and
marriage after divorce and I'm wondering
if I'm just better off living with the
truth in peace if I've left an abusive
marriage I guess first out of the gate
man I'm so sorry that you had to live
with
this thanks yeah it's it's kind of
awkward because a lot of people just
really don't know um I I I left earlier
this year and um I'm trying to focus on
rebuilding my life I've mostly just kept
quiet about it um especially from the
beginning of our marriage and I've been
really protective of my ex in our
relationship I thought I think I guess I
thought that we could work it out
privately and like with marriage
counseling and um no one no one in his
side actually knows what happened or
what he's done and honestly I feel like
there are a lot of things I still don't
know um and I don't want to cause issues
or drama and I really don't want to hurt
people because I feel like it could be
really hurtful to talk about
things um and I'm not sure I'd even be
like heard or listened to but the reason
I'm asking is because I recently ran
into one of his family friends and it
went really sour and I'm just kind of
shaken up and wondering if I did the
right thing by keeping
quiet I want to reframe that for you
okay is that
cool yeah um tell me about the abuse and
then I'll walk you through this
reframe well um it started really early
on it's really strange CU while we were
dating he never like physically
pressured me to do
anything um but within a few days of us
being married he just was very coercive
and controlling and
forceful um you talking about
sexually yeah um and at one point even
like forced himself on me against my
will okay we call that
rape yeah
um and hold let me let me St right there
why does that why does
the why does using that word make you so
uncomfortable I think I'm okay with
recognizing that internally okay but
I've really struggled with
publicly or with other people using that
word because it doesn't reflect the
image of what people typically think of
when they think of rape and I don't want
to take away from other people's
experiences because I know this sounds
bad but I feel like mine's just not as
bad as some other people's and I don't
maybe that's the wrong response but
that's just how I feel I don't
know I I I'm really not going to frame
anything you're saying as right or wrong
okay I don't want you walking around
around with that sort of weight like I
did this
wrong I will tell you that comparing
trauma is an exhaustive Fool's
errand it doesn't make you feel any
better and it doesn't minimize to your
body to your heart to your soul the
violence that was done to
you and having your autonomy
stolen from somebody who got up in front
of your friends and family and God and
says I do
forever is
um can be one of the most
unmorph call
yeah your pain and the hell you've been
through is yours and it's
real and I'm not going going to do
disservice to you by minimizing it
okay okay if that helps you get through
the day on in a regular basis I honor
that your body has been trying to keep
you safe and alive in whatever ways it's
tried to figure out for the last however
many years that's
cool but on this show I want to honor
you enough by saying out loud what
happened
and calling it by the right names and
not saying yeah but one time this
happened worse to somebody else in a
different way I'm not I don't play that
game loss is loss rape is rape violence
is violence abuse is
abuse
okay thank
you all right so continue go
ahead um well I went through all of that
and publicly just pretended like
everything was great while like crying
every day in private
and always talking really wonderfully
about him to both our families um my
family thought he was like the most
wonderful thing um and we were both like
away from our families we didn't have
our families around us and so it's a lot
easier to just kind of act like
everything's okay and then we we went
through um like nine or 10 months of
counseling couples counseling some
individual counseling too over this
incident or just to generally try to
improve your
marriage regarding the abuse cuz I just
couldn't have intimacy again CU I
couldn't feel safe you know of course
did he ever apologize say I'm sorry I
mean what was his posture this whole
time that's a confusing thing because
throughout that process like eventually
one day I broke down like crying and
sogging about how much he hurt me and
like tried to just shove it away and
move on but I couldn't and so that's
when we went to counseling and we also
talked about just in general our
relationship and communication but
specifically regarding what happened and
moving past that and developing intimacy
again um and he was apologetic at the
time and since then he's taken it away
and tried to say it didn't happen um but
yeah long story short initially through
that process things seemed good and
then about after after we stopped
counseling um about a little a year
afterwards or not a year afterwards a
year and a half ago I guess I'm sorry
it's
confusing um for a whole year after that
it was just chaos it was like he didn't
really care about me anymore he wouldn't
talk to me mentally emotionally connect
with me all these really Strange
Behaviors it was like something else was
going on I didn't know what was
happening um I was dealing with a lot of
medical issues at the time
and I kind of hit a point in that year
where I recognized
I didn't feel like I had autonomy and
could make decisions for myself and I
don't know if it was necessarily that I
felt so much pressure from him but I
just felt like something was off and I
had this strange almost like spiritual
experience where I just felt everything
in my body and my mind like aware of it
and just like go and not even like leave
him just go like there's something in
your situation that's off go and so in
the process of trying to evaluate what's
going on in my mar marriage I for like
short periods of time would stay with
one of my close Christian friends
because I just couldn't think clearly
and I couldn't process my emotions
around him I just I don't know why I
think I just didn't feel safe
to um and through that
process it just spiraled it's like the
behavior got so toxic and there was like
lying and gaslighting and triangulating
between me and our families and like he
built up all this chaos and made it just
a toxic relationship to even try to stay
in to try to be
build
and I was on the inside just like trying
to wait for God to change his heart to
be able to try to work things out with
him because I couldn't reason with him
um and it just it got really bad it got
to the point where like I could see him
enjoying seeing me crying I could see
him enjoying hurting me it got to the
point where he convinced me I was like
crazy and tried to like diagnose me with
like a paranoia disorder and like I
almost like was thinking about admitting
myself because I was like oh my gosh
there's something really wrong with me
and if it wasn't for my good close
Christian friends being like you
gaslighting you your concerns are valid
what's going on isn't okay I probably
would have considered really doing that
um and so when when did your how long
youall married we were married for a
little over three years and when is your
divorce
final uh it could be any day now does
the in your divorce decree did you
disclose the
abuse I didn't I didn't tell my lawyer
about um what happened at least until
later in the process and even then it
was like she's like you can
either sue him or not bring it up
because either way like one or the other
it just I don't know why but it just
didn't seem like it was going to be a
helpful thing okay and I didn't I was
away from him at that point so I wasn't
going to like file a restraining order
so thankfully I was safely away so are
you in contact with him anymore or are
you
done um it's mostly just like
finalizing uh the separation of things I
guess is that in
writing yes okay
if you have means not everybody does I
would hire somebody to do
that and are you staying in the home or
is he staying in the home yall selling
it what are you how's this how youall
splitting
up I'm really fortunate at this point
I'm actually living in a different state
from him okay so so what stuff do you
have to go
get I don't have to go get anything else
we've already like separated it all good
okay yeah so
man you've just been through it
huh that's like just one part of the
piece yeah yeah um well I was about to
say you've left out a whole
bunch yeah
yeah yeah and I can tell because you
have very circular evasive language that
I it's a very particular way of talking
that I only hear from people who are in
deeply abusive relationships it it was
real bad wasn't
it it's confusing because like no hold
on hold on I'm not gonna let you do that
it was real bad wasn't
it yeah it got real bad okay yeah here's
what I need you to know
okay you did everything you could to try
to make this thing work
even to the point that it got so unsafe
for you that your body said if you're
not going to leave I
quit
okay yeah you weren't going crazy your
body was saying I'm out because you
don't get the message that we're about
to get killed
here we're living with a
rapist we're living with
a absolute psychopath
and because you wanted to fulfill the
role that the picture you had in your
mind you were so caught off guard
because this wasn't who the guy this
wasn't the guy you dated because the
family things were so nice and they like
everybody performed so well at the
family get togethers and the friend get
togethers and because you wanted to
fulfill your um whatever your faith told
you your job was as a married
woman
you went into autopilot until your body
said I'm
out does that sound
right yeah I
think I I didn't see a way out when I
was in it I know I
know but here's what I need you to hear
me say real directly until you tell the
truth to yourself your body's going to
continue to not trust you to drive and
it's going to drive for
you okay and what that means is you're
going to walk into a meeting and all of
a sudden your heart is going to start
beating 190 beats a minute and your
stomach's going to drop and you're going
to feel so sick and you're not going to
know
why and you're not going to be able to
sleep you're not going to be able to
meet people you see what I'm saying
those are all things that are happening
right
yeah I really struggle with this
Association I know that's your body
saying oh you're not driving I'm out
yeah
okay a lot of that starts with telling
the truth around language and telling
the truth about what actually
happened sitting down with somebody
you've heard me say it a million times
on the show grief Demands a witness I
got to sit in front of somebody else and
say the words my husband raped
me my husband was wildly
abusive I know my husband was cheating
on me because of x y and z
my husband did this and he did this and
you have to say those things
okay with a safe and trusted person now
here's the rub I don't have a good sense
and we could talk for a while longer but
in if we were in a different context but
I don't have a sense that family friends
or his friends or his
F I don't know what benefit there is to
bringing all this up the divorce is
final you're out of their life they
don't get a vote into your life they
don't get to speak into your life they
don't have anything to do with your life
and that lying piece of crap is going to
tell them whatever stories he's going to
make up about you and about the
situation and what a victim he is and
there's not a story I don't believe that
you can tell that they're going to go we
knew it is that
fair probably because the way this
usually plays out is the world looks at
the woman who got victimized and chose
to tr chose silence to keep safe it
wasn't because you were a coward it's
because your body determined you
determined the safest thing for me to do
right now is to be
quiet the outside world says well if it
was so bad why didn't you say something
why didn't you tell us oh because she's
embarrassed she's just making this up
you see what I'm
saying yeah and they don't get a
vote they don't get a vote so I'm asking
you what what benefit would I me who
would you tell what benefit would come I
do see a significant benefit to sitting
down with your family
100%
I haven't spoken with his family but
I've tried to talk to my family and I
think I think only really my brothers
are very supportive um the women in my
family have been really
toxic why
um well
um I don't know there's it's it's hard
for me to understand too
but there's history of abuse and
enabling abuse in the past and so it to
think of me being the one that broke my
marriage and left irresponsibly is
easier than thinking that I was a victim
in a situation for them so they've
they've been married to abusive people
and chosen to to
stay um no they've enabled me to be
abused in the
past ah
gotcha so they've opted out of your life
too yeah my mom basically tried to deny
past abuse that happened right in front
of her and then told me because you said
that was Abus I don't believe you when
you tell me other things are abused wow
okay are you seeing a professional
counselor
I am yeah yeah I am I'm actually excited
to try and start EMDR sometime good in
the next few months good hopefully that
is an excellent excellent excellent um
modality for you to help deal with this
trauma um here's the deal sitting with a
c professional counselor I mean you got
a you got a hard row ahead of
you but pretending or to keep you safe
and not have to deal with the reality of
some of this by using some what I would
call pacifying L language or circular
language like yeah it was really hard um
he made me feel uncomfortable versus
saying what actually happened the words
your body has to know that you are back
in control and the more that you deny it
the more you try to circle around it the
more your body's like oh she doesn't get
the severity of this
thing so you sit down in front of
somebody whether it's your attorney
whether it's your whether it's your
therapist and you say this is what he
did and while we're here this is what my
mom
did this is what the man my stepdad
did and when I brought it up they made
fun of me they mocked me they said
that's not abuse oh
my and whatever whatever whatever
amen I hate this for you so much given
the fact that you have experienced abuse
before and you told your mom and she
didn't believe you it doesn't S it makes
perfect sense that your body
thought oh this is happening again we
can't tell anybody because that that is
not how this problem is solved this
problem is solved through silence and
compliance let's try that because the
last time it cost us our mother and I
need you to hear me say none of this was
your
fault none of this was your
fault I hope you will sit in the
presence of some
trusting quality professional
professionals and that your brothers
some friends at your in your new
community will be trusted safe resources
for you grief Demands a
witness I'm sorry
Miranda